nick offerman thank you so much for
joining me on the show
my pleasure good to see you
um nick you've been encouraging people
to get out and vote
in this coming election for a while now
uh we're eight days away
from election day um why
is this election so important to you and
have you always been political
um when i was younger i was a full-time
hedonist and artist i was a chicago
theater artist
and while i had my heart in the right
place
i had my head buried in my work and so
um i was much more of the kind of person
that i'm talking to today which is
the kind of person that said i'm sure
everything will be taken care of
by wiser heads than my own
and we see where that mentality has
gotten us
um you know we are those of us
that are have um news channels that are
speaking the truth
that are dealing in common sense we're
all aware
that we're uh that we're suffering from
a plague
that can be addressed with um with
wearing masks
and you know with uh with a testing plan
and um that on top of the sort of
criminality that's been espoused in our
administration for four years
makes me just want to say to everybody
it's no one's
driving the boat they're they're looting
our country like we are paying taxes i
pay a
ton of taxes and they're spending it
on ivanka's handbags and i'm
not okay with that and if you are not
okay with that
go vote you we live in a country where
we suppose
we're supposed to be able to pick what
happens but we have to simply get off
our rear ends
and go exercise that incredible right
nick as you well know you're often
associated with your most famous
character ron swanson the similarities
between you both
the woodwork the saxophone uh but not so
much the libertarianism the
anti-government sentiment
your politics are very different to
ron's aren't they and you
you seem to have to tell people that on
multiple occasions
that's true uh ron you know ron is
written
uh brilliantly as a character in a
comedy program that is fictional
and uh while i've read a lot about
libertarianism
and on paper i think it's a great idea
it sounds good
the basic tenets of it but unfortunately
governing any number of human beings
whether it's a car full of children on a
trip
to a county to a state to a nation
requires
a little more parenting than the
libertarians i think would have us
uh apply and so i i'm
not for any over governance or anything
extra
but obviously you know we we strip away
regulations from our corporations and
all they do is pollute
and rape our natural resources you know
um i i think that uh we absolutely need
enough government to provide people with
astonishing things like basic health
care
um and and that is the way that we could
one day see every one of our citizens
treated
with the same amount of decency i don't
think it's fair that
groups of of americans should have to be
saying
why can't i simply get the same
treatment as you straight white people
you said in 2017 nick that ron swanson
would never vote trump because quote
more than politics ron is a good person
does that imply that trump voters that
you believe trump voters aren't good
people that they are
complicit in trump's awfulness and
racism and bigotry and the rest
well it's a real conundrum because
there's so many of them i mean the fact
that this election is
even remotely possibly a contest is just
mind-blowing
and it leads me to believe that um i
i think that once we lost the the
fairness act in
media and allowed you know right-wing
radio and then fox news to become
prevalent
i think that there's probably a lot of
people who want to
consider themselves christians or people
with good values
who sort of unwittingly have begun to
receive their messaging
from these these racist and
xenophobic and homophobic channels and i
think so i think that
that a lot of them have been tricked
into like
espousing their inner fears that they're
uh based in creating some sort of
weather
yeah it's funny you mentioned you know
whether they've been tricked or whether
there's you know just
the propaganda effect of right-wing
media and talk radio
i know that you grew up not in a wealthy
family in a place called manuka illinois
a small town which i think went almost
two to one for trump in 2016.
um what do you think motivates some of
the people you grew up with some of your
neighbors you know
the working class the white working
class people who still
blindly support trump even now
i think i think it's that messaging i
mean i think that uh i do think that
there's
um there's an american comfort
uh that everything's okay in our little
town
and one of the candidates uh says
suddenly or not so subtly that he will
keep our town
white that he will keep immigrants out
of the country
you know he'll keep us safe um
we'll keep things great like like they
used to be
and so you know i think that people
wouldn't like to admit that i think
a lot of the families in my town would
be ashamed
if they could take a step back and see
how they actually are perceived
by those who listen to things like truth
and science
you say in your audiobook all rise which
was supposed to be a live special i know
until
uh covert got in the way that the two
parties are not morally the same the
left's platform is rooted in empathy
whereas
the right you say refuses to engage in
decency
yet you also argue that the country is
the way it is right now
because of all of us how do you square
that i might say you sound like you're
saying it's both sides
well uh a great example i think is is um
you know the policy that the left is
espousing
uh medicare for all you know saying that
in
a nation this wealthy why can't everyone
have guaranteed health care
like so many other developed nations it
seems incredible that we don't
and when we say that the the republicans
say
you dirty socialists you're not going to
do that with my tax dollars
that's a great example of all uh
the left is doing is saying we're trying
to take care of people
i mean this that's where our policies
generally come from
and and the right is so admired in
propaganda
and messaging instead of instead of
offering a counter proposal
they say i would love to see those
liberals cry
like i take pleasure in seeing liberal
tears
and i you know whether i agree with your
policies or not
i don't want to see you in pain like
that scene that's the decency i'm
talking about
i might disagree with with you
politically but i
uh i love you as my neighbor or my
fellow citizen
and i don't want to see you cry
and and so we live in a country where
on paper we're supposed to be able to
use our votes
everybody's vote is supposed to be
weighed
fairly and we've allowed things to erode
to a place where
with voter suppression and
gerrymandering
and there's a great article today about
how
um how in in republican states
with republican secretaries of state uh
when the votes are counted
there's always like a five-point shift
where they're like well
about you know a certain percentage of
the
democratic votes weren't eligible for
you know for some murky reason and so
we've allowed our system to erode
the people are supposed to be able to
pick what happens
but in 2016 the people factually
picked hillary clinton but but
the the nefarious systems that are in
place
slid things to a republican win
with a little help from our friends in
russia
so you mentioned medicare for all how
left are you nick you tweeted earlier
this year
that you had voted for elizabeth warren
in the primaries i'm just wondering like
where do you put yourself on the
spectrum and what do you make of joe
biden given the candidate for the
democrats this time around is not
elizabeth warren
is not bernie sanders well
um i don't i i'm not smart enough to
comprehend all the labels and i think
i think that labeling is one of the
things that gets us in trouble
but of of the incredible menu of
democratic
uh nominees that we had or the
candidates
um i mean any one of them
you know donald trump makes their
janitor look like an incredible
candidate but
but the per the people i agreed with the
most would be
elizabeth warren and bernie sanders so
wherever that places me
um they just make the most sense to me
you know like
the the things they have to say about
the
the incredible disparity of wealth in
our
country you know bernie harps uh
wonderfully
about the incredible increase in wealth
the billionaires have gained
during this pandemic when all of these
people are suffering
when like pennies from these incredible
rich oligarchs you know could literally
feed our country
so that all just makes sense to me i you
know i don't
have a vast uh social leaning
all of that said uh i am
over the moon to have joe biden
captaining our ship
he uh he knows uh the ins and outs uh
for better or worse and uh i i
can't wait uh to to i mean
to to flush what the slump the swamp has
become
clean it out i mean it's going to need
an incredible
uh uh we're not we're going to have to
attempt
on that note nick washington dc and
fumigate it fumigate so on that note
that will require
democrats uh willing to take the fight
to the republicans which they often
don't do
you hit on a lot of political issues in
all rise you take jabs at donald trump
and brett kavanaugh
and his hearings back in 2018 amy coney
barra is on her way to the supreme court
today
what were your views on her confirmation
process do you think democrats did
enough to try and stop
him because i don't i don't no i i agree
with you
uh she and kavanaugh are just an
absolute travesty
um you know they're they're blatant
examples of so many
of the of the uh forcible
policy actions led by by the gravedigger
mitch mcconnell
um the democrats absolutely have to step
up to the plate
and play hardball or we're just going to
continue to be
to be pushed around um
i would be so ashamed if if i were a
constituent of
mcconnell or ted cruz or lindsey graham
or any of these republican leaders who
just
so hypocritically and flatly lie
and cry and fulminate and
and and say like put on these these
incredible
theatrical shows completely black and
white from what they said 10 minutes ago
uh to whatever serves their purpose yeah
that
is scurrilous low bitumerative behavior
and i would be so ashamed to to have
them
be my representative nick well
one last question before i leave you and
thank you for speaking so plainly
uh in addition to all rise you've also
made all your stand-up specials
available to rent or download on your
website with all proceeds
going to america's food fund how did
that come about
well you know it's sort of a side gig i
love working as an actor and a writer
and i learned at some point that i also
enjoy touring as a humorist
and writing things to make people laugh
and and
funny songs and um i'm not good
i'm not good at promoting myself so
after a lot of effort and and years i
finally got a website and i put my my
stuff up
right kind of when the lockdown started
and i said well great now
i'd be a total if i just tried to
promote myself or or make money off of
this
one now that this pandemic has hit but
there you know there are at least 17
people
asking to for this content and for the
sake of those people i said okay
i'm gonna announce this content but i'll
take whatever proceeds i get
and send it to america's food fund which
is one of the great
uh outfits providing food and
for the needy in this time and so you
know
it's the the the money that i would make
off of my
my small humorist career is not going to
make or break me so i'm glad to
to help out with the efforts of so many
great organizations
like the the world uh the world chef's
kitchen with
jose andres i really think those are
those are the heroes and
those are the people that should be
winning trophies these days
the audiobook of all rise is out now and
check out nick's comedy specials at
nickoffman.com
nick offerman thank you so much for
joining me